Ok people, it's time for The Rubin Report
Fan Show, Round 2.
Our first fan show was shot back in May of
2016, which seems like a lifetime ago, and
we are beyond due for another.
If you missed it entirely, we conducted 20
interviews in one day with Rubin Report fans
from all over the world, talking with viewers
from the United States and United Kingdom
to Egypt and Jordan to Switzerland and Sweden.
What mattered more than the diversity of their
geographic location or their color or their
religion was their diversity of thought.
We had selected these 20 fans out of over
1400 submissions, and I promise you, we read
every single one.
These fans wrote us incredibly passionate
essays about their life, their work, and their
countries.
It was virtually impossible to pick the final
20, and I can honestly say I loved every interview
I did.
It was an incredibly long day for us and my
brain was fried after, but it truly was one
of the most rewarding and validating experiences
of my life.
So many people being willing to stand up and
be part of the battle of ideas is everything
I've tried to foster here with this show.
To say it was a humbling experience is beyond
and understatement.
Actually, it was the fan show which really
sparked the idea us taking the show fully
independent.
Just this week we crossed the 100 million
view mark, and I can't think of a better way
to mark this milestone than talking to you,
the fans, directly.
This thing is really taking off and it is
you all who are the rocket fuel.
So far our second Fan Show: rubinreport.com/fanshow,
will take you to a submission page.
Tell us a bit about yourself, where your from,
your age, why you watch the show and anything
else you think is relevant.
Please though, try to keep your submissions
under 10 sentences!
We really loved reading the submissions last
time, but we need to make sure we have the
time to read to them all.
Be smart and succinct, and that'll be your
best way of getting through to us.
If you're one of the 20 fans selected for
an interview, you'll hear from the Rubin Report
team sometime in April.
If you submitted for the last fan show but
weren't selected, please submit again so we're
sure to see you!
And if you live in a place where free speech
isn't so free, please let us know how we can
accomodate, and we'll see what we can do.
By the way if you're a $25 and up member on
Patreon, you've got a Golden Ticket opportunity
to be on the show.
2 of the fan show guests will be selected
from this Patreon pool -- we've got a separate
form for you to fill out over at patreon.com/rubinreport.
So many of you have told me that what we've
done here for the past two years has helped
create conversation in a time when sharing
ideas is becoming increasingly rare.
This is your chance to say what you think
and be seen and heard by people who feel the
same way.
You're just one person but the ultimate minority
is the individual.
And an individual with a good idea can change
the world.
Go to rubinreport.com/fanshow, or click the
link below, and hopefully I'll talk to you
soon!